fadeaway misses their trust you talked
about too many failures in Goa unique
personality that he's ever coached but
he really enjoys coaching them because
he always enjoyed the game as grant
knocked down the loan freaks know
they're so good at OKC being able to
switch even you can switch that's nice
hope knocks down that's a short-range a
you know you Westbrook right now he has
the pace of the game going basketball
game you got to understand the tempo
that you want to play it and the tempo
that the other team player but free
[Applause]
on mobile than I do
good play Ferguson Rondo with between
the oil too much you see the Lakers are
playing loose they're coming out they're
shooting a lot of threes finishing out
the season yeah and I thought he was
fantastic guys had to begin the season
playing with LeBron of those guys that
he could be a huge factor coming off the
bench for the Thunder
let's watch this offensive execution
right now built play by Paul George
stepping out only gets the wrong nice
kick and nice delivery from Russell
Westbrook to Paul George all of these
players not only can he be a coach on
the floor but he can also critique him
on the floor which I've seen Sweden
going back to a perfect health - my
brother Russell whispered with the pass
in the world
they were plus threes in the first half
but also I was a little disturbed by
looking at this stat once was looking
want some scuffing from the feel right
now 2 of 13 from the field but assist
another assist by Russell Westbrook 16
assists Ferguson with the 3 3 mrs.
[Applause]
Russell again from the other off the
glass on purpose the bounce pass and
finish by Russell Westbrook does he miss
it
let's see what a thunder go pick and
roll to the basket my friend I met his
sister Russell with right penises music
Google oh goodness
drop off a sudden that's 20 assists rule
1 brain okay she's gonna add their two
game losing streak finally win again
here
[Applause]
deeply finally what goes in defensive
zone fungi in the game
ooh daddy
[Applause]
go easy hustle we just watch history
here we